In China, officials announced that the number of new coronavirus cases...
...has decreased in regions outside of Hubei province, the epicenter of the outbreak.
They also say the daily increase across the mainland fell below 2,000 for the first time.
In Japan, 88 more coronavirus cases have been confirmed on quarantined cruise ship Diamond Princess,...
...bringing the number to 542.
Chinese officials said they planned to bring back 352 Hong Kong residents on board the ship.
In Afghanistan, Ashraf Ghani was voted president for his second term,...
...the election commission announced.
The delayed result comes nearly five months after the election took place...
...and follows allegations of vote-rigging.
In Croatia, newly-elected President Zoran Milanovic was sworn into office.
Milanovic won the presidential election in early January.
Finally from Uganda, thirteen Rwandan nationals being held on multiple charges were released by Uganda.
Foreign Affairs Minister Sam Kutesa says the decision was made as a gesture of goodwill.